inner monologue is about sort of all the
things that I feel and think about on a
daily basis it talks about love you know
heartbreak and anxiety and depression
and a lot of things that I feel like
people some people are like super
comfortable with hearing about yet and
that kind of stuff but I really wanted
it to be as true to me as possible
yeah and and it's become really special
you know I really think you like attract
like-minded people so every time we do a
show and they're all singing with me
it's like okay this is this is exactly
what I wanted and why I did this you
know the people are out there but were
you a little bit shocked just how
relatable those themes were when people
when you started hearing from people
where you started seeing the numbers of
like-minded people who were going
through the same thing what was that
like totally it was overwhelming
sometimes I do like meet and greets and
I'll get some really intense stories
yeah but for the most part it's it's
beautiful to know that you know none of
us are really alone even when we think
we are yeah like we have way more in
common than we all think we do were
there people trying to steer you away
from being that open on the on the
record or know you very much call the
shots
ya know what if they were I would have
told them to f off perfect the
relationship with you and Selena is
awesome on record what is it like in
real life it's it's it's the same yeah
same as you would think I mean I love
her to death I I think she's so strong
and she's just so beautiful and humble
and I'm grateful that I even get to be
around her
yeah learned from her and she's gone
through a lot and when you are sort of
that open with fans whether it's Selena
with what she went through or you
talking about the themes on the album
does that make a connection with the two
of you sitting down to do a song
together even better when you both have
sort of super young but have gone
through so much well I can't speak for
her but I can say that you know
perspective is everything yeah
and I think there's a lot of
contributing factors that go into
writing a song I think I think probably
for me more so it's personal experience
yeah than it is about people around me
yeah at first I think it starts as me
and then it becomes about the people
around me
do you write better when you're in a
dark place Oh see I don't I don't know I
think it depends on my mood like I read
it I write a majority of stuff when I'm
feeling upset but if I'm in love with
somebody or something then I'm like like
I was super in love when I made any
monologue and I wrote a song code deep
under this uncut Apple that song in a
Morlock when I was super in love yeah
and it was just like two of those songs
that just like flowed right out of me so
and that love's not around anymore
oh no no okay so how what's your
relationship like with those songs that
you write when you're super in love
afterwards they feel a little bitter but
but I find that as you as you the more
you do this and the more life you live
the the more you have things to
associate them with other than so it may
it may be one thing when you write it
but it could take on a completely other
form later down the line knowing when
you're on tour and you're touring with
pink that we all know what a pink show
looks like so what what does that do for
you knowing that you have to hit that
stage first knowing what is to come you
know to be honest what her and I do are
completely different I like that I get
to just like you know warm up the crowd
for her yeah and and then just to see
everyone's face when she's twirling
around the arena like in six-inch heels
all the way around and people just like
don't know what to expect and it's fun I
like I like I like being on the stage
but I also like getting off because the
faster I get off that means the faster
she gets on and I get to watch it -
you've opened for some really incredible
acts what has that experience sort of
what have you taken away individually
from all the big artists that you've
opened
for that you then bring on your own
shows when you're when you're headlining
is it an attitude is that how you treat
people is definitely how you treat
people
yeah for sure I've been I've been lucky
enough to be an opener and open with a
lot of my friends and I've heard horror
stories about how some people treat
their openers and how they treat people
and yeah I just don't ever want to like
run my ship like that ever no so yeah I
think if anything it's taught me to like
just be appreciative of all the things
that we get to do and even though it can
be kind of mentally draining you know
when I like just sleep for 82 hours you
know the bigger picture is you know you
get to do what you love every day yeah
what do you do live when it's it's
either a sound that you did with Selena
or with Nile or what do you do live with
those songs when you have most of the
time I just sing them yeah just as this
or or I'll have the audience the crowd
see seeing their parts but yeah most of
the times just me yeah your relationship
with Niall how's that that's good yeah
yeah he's a sweetheart what do you got
what do you where did you guys connect
where what son sort of what level did
did you guys find common ground well we
actually met at them much Music Awards
oh you did yeah in Canada and that was
when we first initially met and then he
asked me to go on tour with him last
spring yeah so we were around each other
for like three months straight mm-hmm so
we've just become good friends from that
and when I wrote what a time I knew I
wanted to have a male's perspective on
it and I've just always loved niles
voice and I just love him as a person
and I sent it to him and was like if you
like this this could be fun you just
come like knocking here like with the
black with pink how did you meet pink
like what was that first meeting like
because you'd work together before the
tour yeah I met her actually through Max
Martin okay um Liat started a little
idea together and she had heard it and
was like I really love this start it was
like just a bare-bones little start and
it's like I really want to finish it
with you can I meet you and I was like I
don't know it's just yeah totally yep
then we ended up doing a another song
together and and doing a charity song
together to that that we did and and we
were supposed to do something together
like us some event together and I didn't
end up panning out and we knew she was
going on tour and I think our managers
were talking and they're like hey we
don't have anything to do this spring
and then I just yeah and then she was
like absolutely we'd love to have you
part one is what this yeah this one is
is there a part two there will be a part
two
yeah and the way that you tell the story
is that it's not dark yeah I I think
because anxiety and depression are so
dark yeah I I wanted it to be I just
didn't want it to be so heavy sure it's
almost like almost like being able to
laugh at yourself a little bit you and
even though you're feeling like absolute
crap yeah you're wonderful yeah thanks
for hanging out with me again yeah
thanks for having me no that was awesome
you